so let's say that we've got the curve r
defined so this is our curve r it's x of
t times i
plus y of t times j it's a curve in two
dimensions on the x y plane
and let's graph it or just graph it in
kind of a in generalized form
so that's our y-axis this is our x-axis
our curve r might look something like
this it might look something let me draw
a little bit more of a
maybe it looks something like this maybe
that's just part of it and as t
increases we're going in that direction
right over there
what i want to do in this video and this
is really more vector algebra than
vector calculus is think about at any
given point here whether we can figure
out a normal vector in partic in
particular a unit normal vector
obviously if you can figure out a normal
vector you can just divide it by its
magnitude and you will get the unit
normal vector so i want to figure out at
any given point a vector that's popping
straight out in that direction
and has a magnitude one so that would be
our unit normal vector and to do that
first we'll think about what a tangent
vector is and from a tangent vector we
can figure out the normal vector and it
really goes back to some of what you
might have done in algebra 1 or algebra
2 of if you have a slope of the line the
negative reciprocal of that slope is
going to be the slope of the
perpendicular line we're going to see a
very similar thing when we do it right
over here with the vector with this
vector algebra so the first thing i want
to think about is how do we construct
how do we construct a
tangent line
well you can imagine at some t
at some t this is what our position
vector is going to look like so call
that r1
r1 right over there and then if we wait
if we allow t to go up a little bit if t
is time we wait a little while a few
seconds however we're measuring things
and then r2 might look something like
this this is f when t has has gotten a
little bit larger we're further down the
path
and so one way that you can approximate
the the the slope of the tangent line or
or the the slope between these two
points for now is essentially the
difference between these two vectors the
difference between these two vectors is
you could view that
you could view that as
delta
delta r this vector plus that vector is
equal to that vector or r2 minus r1 is
going to give you this delta r right
over here and as r2 as that increment
between r1 and r2 gets smaller and
smaller and smaller as we have a smaller
and smaller t increment as we get a
smaller and smaller t increment
so we get a smaller and smaller t
increment the slope of that delta r is
going to more and more approximate the
slope of the tangent line all the way to
the point that if you have an infinitely
small change in t so you have a dt so
you go from r then you just you change t
very a very small amount that delta r
and we can kind of conceptualize that as
dr then does approximate the at a
tangent vector so if you have a very
small change in t
then
your very small
delt dr i'll call it because now we're
talking about a differential
your very small differential right over
here that is a tangent that is a tangent
vector so dr dr is
a
tangent
tangent vector at any at any given point
and once again all of this is a little
bit of review but dr we can write as dr
is equal to dx
times i
plus the infinite infinitesimally small
change in x times the i unit vector plus
the infinitesimally small change in y
times the j unit vector and you see that
you see that if i were to draw if i were
to draw a curve let me just draw another
one actually i don't even have to draw
the axes if our dr looks like that
if that is our dr
then
we can break that down into its vertical
and horizontal components this right
over here is d y
and that right over there
that right over there is
that is dx and so we see that dx times i
actually this is dx times i and this is
d y
this is d y times j d y is the magnitude
j gives us the direction
dx is the magnitude i tells us that
we're moving in the horizontal direction
over here this actually would be a
negative this must be a negative value
right over here and this must be a
positive value based on the way that i
drew it so that gives us a tangent
vector and now we want to from that
tangent vector figure out a normal
vector a vector that is essentially
perpendicular to this vector right over
here and there's actually going to be
two vectors like that there's going to
be the vector that kind of is
perpendicular in the right direction
because we care about direction or the
vector that's perpendicular in the left
direction we can pick either one but for
this video i'm going to focus on the one
that goes in the right direction we're
going to see that that's going to be
useful in the next video when we start
doing a little bit of vector calculus
and so let's think about what that might
be and what i'll do to make it a little
bit clearer let me draw dr again
i'll draw a dr like this
this is our dr
this is dr and then this right over here
this
right over there we already said this is
d y
times i
and then this sorry that's d y times j
we're going in the vertical direction d
y times j and then in a different color
this right i already used that color
let's see i haven't used well i haven't
used
that blue yet so this right over here is
dx dx times i
so we know from our algebra courses you
take the negative reciprocal so there's
going to be something about swapping
these two things around and then taking
the negative one but we have to figure
out well we want the one that goes to
the right so which one should we use so
let's think about it a little bit
if we if we take d y times i so we take
this length but taught in the i
direction we're going to get
we're going to get this
we're going to get that so this is d
y
times i
and then if we were to
if we were to take d if we were to just
take dx
times
j that would take us down because dx
must be negative here since it's pointed
to the left so we have to swap the sine
of dx to go upwards so we swap the sine
of dx
to go upwards because obvious here was
it was a negative sign it went leftwards
we wanted to go upwards so this is going
to be negative
negative dx times j we're now moving in
the vertical direction and that at least
visually this isn't kind of a rigorous
proof that i'm giving you but this is
hopefully good
a good visual representation that that
does that that does get you i should
have drawn it a little bit
that does get you pretty
that gets you pretty close just visually
inspecting it to what looks like the
perpendicular line it's consistent what
what you learned in algebra class as
well that we're taking the negative
reciprocal we're swapping the x's and
the y's
or the change in x and the change in y
and we're taking the negative of one of
them
and so we have our normal line just like
that
our normal vector so a normal vector is
going to be
d y i
minus d x j but then if we want to
normalize it we want to divide by by
that magnitude so a normal let me write
it this way a normal vector so let me
call this i'll just call it a
a normal vector is going to be d y times
i
is going to be d y times i
minus dx times j
minus dx times j i'll do that same blue
color minus
dx
times j
now if we want this to be a unit normal
vector we have to divide it by the
magnitude of a but what is the magnitude
of a the magnitude of a
is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to the square
root of
i'll start with the dx squared so it's
the negative dx squared which is just
going to be dx squared same thing as
positive dx squared
is going to be dx squared plus dy
squared
plus
dy squared i could have put the negative
right in here but then when you square
it that negative would disappear
but this thing right over here and we
saw this when we first started exploring
arc length this thing right over here is
the exact same thing as as ds and i know
there's no ds that we've shown right
over here but we've seen it multiple
times that when you're when you're
thinking about if you if you think about
the length of dr as ds that's exactly
what this thing right over here is so
this can also be written as ds the
infinitesimally change in the arc length
but it's a scalar quantity you're not
concerned you're just concerned with the
absolute distance you're not concerned
so much with the direction you could
another way to view it is it's the
magnitude it's the magnitude right over
here of dr so now we have everything we
need to construct our unit normal vector
a unit normal vector at any point and
i'll now write n and i'll put a hat on
top of it say that this is a unit normal
vector we'll have magnitude 1 is going
to be equal to
a divided by this or we could even write
it this way so we could write it as
multiple ways we can write it we can
write it as i'll write it in this color
as d y times i
minus dx times j
and then all of that
times or let me not time divided by ds
divided by the magnitude of this so
divided by
ds and obviously i could distribute it
on each of these
on each of these terms but this right
here we've been able to construct a unit
normal vector at any point on this curve